[Música]
israel continuó con su campaña de
bombardeos y atacó túneles utilizados
por el grupo islamista hamás en la
franja de gaza donde tras 10 días de
conflicto ya se registran al menos 219
muertos y más de 50.000 desplazados
palestinos el gobierno de benyamín
netanyahu está examinando si se reúne
las condiciones para un alto el fuego
que clama la comunidad internacional
descienden las tensiones entre españa y
marruecos luego de que la policía
marroquí cerró el paso fronterizo del
tarajal e interrumpió el éxodo
migratorio que permitió la entrada en la
ciudad española de ceuta de cerca de
8000 migrantes la canciller española
arantxa gonzález aseguró que su país
quiere tejer puentes pero seguirá firme
en la defensa de su integridad
territorial y sus fronteras
en francia los ciudadanos pueden
disfrutar a partir de hoy de las
terrazas restaurantes y bares luego de
más de seis meses de cierre por cuenta
de la pandemia de coke 19 el presidente
de manuel macro no quiso escenificar
esta reapertura acudiendo a una de ellas
para tomarse un café junto a su primer
ministro jan castex y lanzó un mensaje
de prudencia
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 cierro blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo con el conflicto entre
israel y gaza en el décimo día de
escalada bélica hoy se registraron
nuevos enfrentamientos y lanzamientos de
cohete desde el enclave y más de 120
bombardeos israelíes sobre objetivos
militares del movimiento islamista hamás
según informó el ejército israelí
estos ataques se elevaron la cifra de
palestinos muertos en gaza a por lo
menos 219 desde el inicio de esta actual
escalada incluidos 63 niños 36 mujeres y
16 ancianos según el recuento del
ministerio de sanidad de gaza del lado
israelí han sido 12 víctimas fatales
ante esto el gobierno del primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu seguro que
está examinando si se reúnen las
condiciones para un alto el fuego
multitudes de palestinos salieron a las
calles y las colinas en cisjordania el
martes tras el llamado de numerosas
organizaciones a una huelga general en
solidaridad con los palestinos en gaza y
jerusalén veamos el informe
sus cánticos afirman que están
dispuestos a dar su vida y su sangre los
palestinos de cisjordania se movilizaron
de forma masiva el martes el llamado a
la unidad en solidaridad con gaza y
jerusalén llegó a locales de todas las
edades por primera vez hay un solo
pueblo palestino de norte a sur de gaza
cisjordania y en jerusalén viene el
resto de nuestra tierra somos un desde
la segunda intifada hace 20 años rara
vez se han visto multitudes en estos
lugares
esta pronto escalo tomando a muchos
fuera por sorpresa escuchamos disparos
de pistola desde el otro lado fue
realmente inesperado show y escuchamos
disparos del lado palestino parece algo
así y entonces las fuerzas israelíes
dispararon mucho gas lacrimógeno y
munición real y cast away frank
al aire aumenta la paranoia se desborda
estos jóvenes creían haber capturado a
oficiales israelíes estos jóvenes están
convencidos de haber frustrado una
infiltración de agentes israelíes
encubiertos
los manifestantes locales les cuentan
que los eventos que tienen lugar en
estas colinas de cisjordania están
claramente conectados con los eventos de
gaza y jerusalén y dicen que no ven un
final inmediato a la violencia
y tras la visita a ceuta y melilla el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez la policía marroquí selló el
paso fronterizo del tarajal
interrumpiendo el paso de migrantes
fueron más de 8000 los que llegaron a
territorio español en las últimas 48
horas entretanto ibrahim ghali el líder
del frente polisario y presidente de la
república árabe de sahraoui democrática
quien se encuentra hospitalizado en
españa' se negó a firmar una situación
de audiencia nacional por presuntos
crímenes de guerra
una visita urgente mientras las
tensiones diplomáticas entre madrid y
rabat siguen aumentando el presidente
del gobierno español pedro sánchez viajó
el martes a ceuta en el norte de
marruecos tras la entrada de un número
récord de emigrantes en el pequeño
enclave español alrededor de 8000
personas llegaron a ceuta en tan solo 48
horas sin que los guardias marroquíes lo
impidieran ya sea nadando o haciendo el
viaje en pequeñas embarcaciones y balsas
en esta imagen el ejército español rodea
a las personas que aún están en el agua
y las devuelve al mar a golpes un viaje
que merece la pena para estos migrantes
si no no hay trabajo así que no tenemos
dinero no hay dinero para mi casa para
mis hijos
los jóvenes de este país están asqueados
no hay trabajo no hay médicos no hay
hospitales no hay nada es cacho canchón
un día mujeres que dejaban a sus hijos
en casa otros con sus bebés en brazos
mientras intentaban cruzar a nado era un
caos toque solos para que os aunque será
en vano para la mayoría el ministerio
del interior español dijo que la mitad
de los llegados de han sido devueltos a
marruecos a primera hora del martes
madrid convocó al embajador marrón
le he recordado que el control de las
fronteras ha sido y debe seguir siendo
la responsabilidad de españa y de
marruecos junto con el otro enclave
norteafricano de españa' melilla ceuta
tiene la única frontera terrestre de la
unión europea con áfrica lo que la
convierte en un imán para los migrantes
que buscan entrar en europa desde las
playas situadas a unos kilómetros al sur
en marruecos hasta ahora rabat ha
aceptado la devolución en caliente de
casi 5000 migrantes más de la mitad de
los que cruzaron la frontera en los
últimos dos días vamos ahora hasta
francia a partir de hoy los franceses
pueden disfrutar nuevamente de terrazas
restaurantes y bares tras seis meses de
cierre por cuenta de la pandemia el
presidente de manuel macro no quiso
asistir a esta reapertura acudiendo a
una terraza para tomarse un café junto a
su primer ministro jan castex de ese de
parís nuestra periodista natalia ruiz
con todos los detalles
un día muy esperado para los franceses
que vuelven a gustarle un poco más de
libertad después de casi siete meses con
la reapertura no solamente de comercios
esenciales sino también de cafés de
restaurantes y también de sitios
culturales algunos aprovecharon para ir
muy temprano a la función de cine de
ocho de la mañana a otros para regresar
esos viejos hábitos como tomarse un café
antes de comenzar todas las actividades
del día ya a este momento son la hora
del almuerzo ya hay muchas personas que
están llegando a las diferentes terrazas
de restaurantes y cafés hay que saber
que estos establecimientos pueden
recibir público pero con un aforo
limitado y únicamente en terraza es
decir únicamente en exteriores o al
menos por ahora también se fuera que las
horas de la tarde-noche con la hora de
la cena pues se también haya bastante
afluencia de público eso sí tendrá que
ser una cena temprano porque el 'toque
de queda' continúa solo que esta vez
comienza a partir de las nueve de la
noche esto a partir de este día
miércoles hay muchas expectativas mucha
expectativa en el país con esta
reapertura que se espera sea sostenida a
largo plazo y también de las reactivas
de la economía todo esto va a la par de
unas cifras mucho mejores por parte de
la epidemia ya que la tasa de incidencia
está por debajo de los 150 casos por
100.000 habitantes en todo el país y que
la campaña de vacunación se ha acelerado
con un poco más de 20 millones de
franceses que ya recibieron al menos la
primera dosis de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19
en américa latina' a colombia se prepara
para una nueva jornada de movilizaciones
masivas hoy miércoles en el marco del
paro nacional entretanto el ministro de
defensa diego molano fue citado por el
congreso en la república a un debate de
moción de censura donde se espera
responda por las denuncias de uso de la
fuerza pública colombia registra más de
40 muertos desde el inicio de estas
protestas veamos el informe que ha
preparado más romeros
organizaciones sociales convocan marchas
en todo colombia unas marchas que
demuestran que el llamado paro nacional
está lejos de concluir
después de tres semanas de
movilizaciones continuas el diálogo
entre los sindicatos y el gobierno de
iván duque está estancado a pesar de las
reuniones entre ambas partes todavía no
se ha instalado una mesa de negociación
los líderes sindicales denuncian que no
hay diálogo posible mientras el gobierno
no reconozca su responsabilidad en las
muertes de manifestantes a manos de la
policía y desmilitarice las ciudades más
de 40 personas han muerto durante las
protestas desde el 28 de abril y ese
proceso no ha podido arrancar porque
ahora el gobierno no acepta otro asunto
supremamente importante parar la
violencia que desató desde el 28
parar esa violencia contra el legítimo
derecho a la protesta tu que está lejos
de dejar de recurrir a la fuerza pública
para hacer frente a las protestas
recientemente anunció el máximo
despliegue de las fuerzas de seguridad
para desbloquear las vías que siguen
cortadas por los manifestantes en varios
puntos del país mientras tanto anunció
algunas medidas sociales no negociadas
con los convocantes del paro empezaremos
a partir del próximo primero de julio un
programa de generación de empleo juvenil
que empieza con subsidiar el equivalente
al 25 por ciento del salario mínimo
legal mensual unas medidas que no son
suficientes para las organizaciones que
ni siquiera representan la totalidad de
las protestas
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúen con nosotros muy
buen día
[Música]
nuestro ser